-It's kind of sweet.
-It's sweet?
-Yeah, I mean, it should be...
I guess it should be disgusting.
Rich, debauched, famous people
just [bleep] on a boat,
but it's -- it's -- it's --
It's, like, super wholesome.
It's -- It's romantic.
-Hey, you guys. Welcome back.
We're here with
Taylor Schilling,
and that was "Pam & Tommy."
-Yeah.
-And there you are
with Seth Rogen,
and a lot has been written about
how Sebastian Stan
and Lily James,
they have to spend so much time
in the makeup chair to look like
Pam and Tommy.
You guys less so.
-Well, what I would do is I
would go and they'd put a wig on
my head and then
I'd eat a sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
I'd go back into my trailer
and I'd eat.
-Yeah.
So this was like the dream gig.
-The dream gig.
It took them so much time.
They're so brilliant.
And they both -- They, you know,
50 bazillion hours
in hair and makeup.
And it was me
and Nick Offerman and Seth --
[ Laughs ]
Just put a hat on
and went to crafty.
[ Laughter ]
-You had some very,
very '90s hair.
That's a fantastic look
right there.
-That's right before I ate
my sandwich.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-That was me alone
in my trailer.
-You're like, "You know what?
I'm going to get the picture
before the sandwich."
-I'm gonna get the picture
before the sandwich.
-And here's another.
That's kind of nicer hair there.
-Aww.
-Did you have some '90s hair
that you'd be embarrassed by now
personally?
-Um...
No. I once, when I was in sixth
grade, tried to cut my hair
like Maria from
"The Sound of Music."
-Oh, wow.
-And I was too old to do that.
You know that photograph?
You know that --
You know that look of
Julie Andrews?
-Yeah.
-It's a bowl cut essentially,
when she's singing
on the mountaintop.
-Yes.
-And I was too old to do that.
I was like 11. So all the kids
were -- It didn't go over well.
-Did you do it yourself or did
you have a professional do it?
-I mean, a professional did it,
but, you know...
-Was it one of those things
that you immediately knew
when you went to school that
it was the wrong call?
-Yes. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Or did you know, like,
when you saw...
-Wait. I have an amazing photo.
The next time I see you,
I'll show you.
I can see the photo.
I'm sorry I don't have any --
I can't show it now.
-I like that
you went to show me.
-I thought I had my phone.
-Like this is some magic place
where whatever you imagine
is here.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't even bring my phone
with me.
-Well, you're not supposed to
bring your phone out here.
-No, I know, but I left it
in the haunted house.
I didn't even bring it with me.
It's in Brooklyn.
-Oh, you didn't bring it
to the show?
-No!
-You can't leave a phone
in a place like that!
-I know! I know!
-The ghosts are gonna be going
crazy on your Instagram.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I didn't even bring it.
-Alright, but you do have
a photo of the haircut?
-Yes, because I -- At the time,
I had glasses and I would
ride horses, but I'd wear,
like, a Western --
like a cowboy hat
while I'd ride the horses.
-Uh-huh.
-Not a helmet.
-Okay.
-It's so weird. It's so weird.
-So you had a Julie Andrews
haircut, cowboy hat, glasses.
-Yes.
-And you thought like,
"This is gonna rule."
-I thought this was it.
-And then you walked in
the door, like,
waiting for everybody -- like
the record-scratch moment.
-Yeah. We're like,
"Not what we were thinking."
[ Laughter ]
You know, but I hadn't yet found
the people that would have
thought that was adorable.
-Sometimes you have to live
later in life to find people
that go for glasses,
cowboy hat, Julie Andrews.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
They understand my aesthetic.
-Is it true that you tried to
change your name in the '90s?
-Oh, yes.
-Okay.
-Yeah, I tried to change my name
in the '90s.
I got tired of being confused
as a boy,
which probably had something to
do with my bowl cut, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Now that I'm thinking about it.
-You were maybe doing
a lot of things
that were adding
to the confusion.
-I was adding to the confusion.
But [bleep] I didn't even really
think of that until right now.
I'm like, "That was probably
because of my haircut."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You were, like, saying to
your parents like,
"Why'd you you name me Taylor?"
-"Why'd you name me Taylor?"
-And they're like, "Honey..."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
So I was upset about my name,
but, really, I was upset about
the bowl cut.
But I was upset about my name,
so I ch--
[ Laughs ]
I changed it to Tally.
-Tally?
-Yeah.
-How do you spell Tally?
-T-A-L-L-Y.
-Okay.
-I don't think I knew
what a Tally was,
and I did it for one season of
my soccer league.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah.
-But these were people that you
had grown up with, right?
It wasn't a new school
or anything.
-No. No.
-So you had to --
That's a weird thing --
-That was really weird too.
-Yeah, when you show up
and you're like,
"Hey, news flash."
-"My name's Tally."
-Yeah.
-And it's a weird name.
-I had a song. It'd be like...
♪ Tally-ho and Ranger Joe ♪
[ Laughter ]
That was it.
-Well, that's helpful.
-♪ Tally-ho and Ranger Joe ♪
♪ They go together ♪
-Well, that's good because
when you have a new name,
I think you almost have to
bring a theme song
to help people remember.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't believe I just
remembered that on TV with you.
I think it was like,
♪ Tally-ho and Ranger Joe ♪
♪ They go together,
they should get married ♪
[ Laughter ]
-And then was there just like
a long silence
from your soccer team
as they were like, "Okay"?
[ Laughter ]
-They were like,
"Put your sombrero away
and get on the field!"
[ Laughter ]
-Were you good at soccer?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I wouldn't be sitting here
with you
if I was good at things
like soccer.
-Wait, this is your fallback?
Being bad a soccer?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Your coach took you aside
and was like, "Listen, Taylor,
Tally, I don't know what it is.
Soccer's not going to work out,
but you could be
a talk-show-host guest one day."
-Yeah, yeah.
-And here you are.
-And here I am.
-Turns out your coach was right.
Hey, it is always nothing less
than a total pleasure
to see you.
-Yeah.
-Thanks for being back.
Good luck at that apartment.
It sounds awesome.
Please don't invite me over.
You guys...
[ Laughter ]
...that's Taylor Schilling.
"Pam & Tommy" is now available
to stream on Hulu.